[Musique]
tu fais comme si j'avais pu choisir
j'avais quoi comme solution aller au
procès supposons que je sois l'un des
patients
qu'est ce que tu me dis je te dit de
battre ouais
[Musique]
montrer son corps dans cette ancienne
autres poursuites et fois médecin parce
que c'est lui ouais c'est lui c'est
parfait maison isolée loin de tours
mon frère à votre femme et votre fille
à toi de jouer et docks si mon frère y
passe j'te descend je paie ma fille je
bute ta femme et je peux tout [ __ ]
vieux on va s'en sortir
c'était le grand manitou dans le coin
joue pas au héros je vais commencer à
ouvrir mort de nathan
on doit reprendre le contrôle
je viendrai vous chercher je dois quand
même
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tuer à tirer
sortez d'ici tout de suite
[Musique]
affaire
je sortais un vrai dur à cuire
[Musique]